Ngoài phố nơi vụ yêu cầu các địa phương hoàn thành báo cáo về tiền lương,
nở luôn và kế hoa thường tách dừng lịch tết muyên đàn hai nghỉ khúc trọng hai
mì sấu, trước ngày 20, 20, 20, 20, 20, 20, 20.
Theo công văn người dân nổi vụ các tình thành phố, bố nơi vụ đề nghỉ phối hợp với các thử
quan lên quan theo gió tình hình sản xuất kinh giói người sống và quan hệ lâu động trong
dân nghiệp, tăng cường tên chuyên phố biến pháp lật lâu động và đề mạnh kìm tra việc
thực thi chính sách, ký thời xử li ví pham.
Các địa phương cũng được yêu cầu chú đậm trên khai dạy pháp phòng người trên chấp,
đình công báo đầm ông định an định chật tự trong dịch tết.
Bộ nội vụ đề nghỉ hỗ trợ dân nghiệp và công bản dàn xác sói
điều trình hợp đồng lâu động, phá ước tập thể quý trế trả lương thường phố hợp thực tiến,
đồng thời yêu cầu dân nghiệp xây dự phương an thường, cân cụ kết và kinh giói
năng hai nghỉnh khúc trọng hai mề lâm và thông bảo sớm trong người lâu động.
Các điều phương phải khảo sát tổng hợp tình gình lương, nợ lương và kinh vách thường tết
rồi về vộ nội vụ trước hàn báo gáo chức đo cho thấy mất thường tết
mình đàn ất tị, hành nghiệp khúc trọng hai mề lâm, bình quan đặt bẩy
phy mềm hai chậu đồng mùt rồi, tưởng tết dựng lịch, bình quan tùy mùt
phay bối mi sọng chậu đồng mùt rồi, tuy lại hình dân nghiệp, tà vị trí công việc.